well what do you consider the minimum
cost a filmmaker should spend on their
festival run and will do
season versus beginner what's the
minimum cost I don't know that there is
a minimum cost I mean it's possible to
spend nothing I think you want to think
of it more in terms of how how many
vessels do you want to play I think is
more a more of a I think you want to
play if you you really want to play 10
to 15 Pesta poles if you can over the
course of a year to 16 months so I think
you as you get close to finishing your
movie I think you want to look at okay
we think we'll be done by May so we can
it's maybe kind of too late to submit
definitely too late to submit to Tribeca
or LA probably tailored to spend to
Toronto so maybe we do try an early
submission of Sundance and slam if it's
the first time your first two filmmakers
lament because then that's only takes
first-time filmmakers to their
competition category okay we're going to
submit to those two after that will
submit to regional festivals you know
that we can submit to reasonably far
enough in advance that we're getting
early submission fees and we have a
better chance of getting in and then you
start looking at the schedule and and
again talk to a filmmaker find which
ones you want to hit but I think you
want to try to get into 10 to 15 which
means applying to 40 to 60 festivals but
applying early where it's like $35
whatever is more advantageous and do it
slowly don't do it all at once because
festivals well I mean first of all a lot
of Fussell's aren't open yet but also as
you start to play once you start to play
you start getting invited other places
oh I heard about your film and we want
to admit you this festival or you know
it's a programmer at Waterfront that's
our film liked it and recommended it to
several other festivals so we don't been
submitted to four or five of the
festival's for free because just because
she heard of it so um you know I think
do it slowly roll out slowly and dip
your toe in the water a little bit
because if you've done 10 submissions
and you haven't gotten into anything and
they're not and and there's a ver and
you've gotten some smaller festivals and
there's some regional festivals in there
and no one's biting then you might want
to take a look at your movie and May
before festivals but this you know again
like do your research as festivals for
everything if your films you know if
it's reasonably well made and you know
regardless of what it is you should be
able to get some decent festival play
because most films aren't reasonably
well made
that's really big that the trick is they
say oh you know there's 10,000 features
made a year but only you know 1000 are
watchable in anyway only thousand have
real actors or you know it's a much
smaller pool so there's you know there's
there's a place for place for you it's
funny I get John it's genre dependent to
like I've learned that comedies have an
easier time getting programmed and
dramas and the romantic comedies have an
easier time than that because festivals
have to program a certain amount of
lighter material to older audiences I
mean alrights has come in and they want
to see you know things that are
different they don't wanna see
blockbusters you want to harken back to
time movies didn't suck so bad you know
the Hollywood ones but they also are you
know relatively conservatives they
occasionally want to see a love story
rather than all the dark d'urgell stuff
that most filmmakers like myself tend to
pour out so very often not I'll see your
manic comedy and I've seen some good
ones I have but often I'll go to a
festival see romantic comedy I'll go
that wasn't so good because it's a
romantic comedy they had to program to
and they only found one that they liked
the other one it's kind of just in there
but yeah there's there's a place for
everything so that's really there's no
minimum and you can get waivers and you
can get recommendations there's no
reason you can't spend zero but you want
to make sure your throw is big enough
that you take advantage of the circuit
that you're able to play a good
smattering around the country because
when you do go to VOD DVD whether you do
it through gravitas Pictures film buff
or by yourself you want your film to
have access to an audience favor will
have played 12 film festivals on its
film festival run and we have one more
coming up and we have I think it's an
average of 30,000 attendees
/ festal that's the average so that's
360,000 people that have been exposed to
our advertising material
thanks to these non sundance festivals
no these these regional Fussell's
they're all over the country so that's
pretty good throw and when we come out
on VOD in April 1st April 1st we come on
in VOD I'm gonna be writing every one of
those vessels saying hey you know can
you go on Twitter and tweet about us can
you know you have a newsletter can you
put us in your newsletter can you send
an email I'll be email blast out to your
email people can your to your mailing
list can you put it in the news items in
your webpage and festivals even though
the festival only runs part of the year
they're operating year-round they want
to stay relevant year round so some on
their own theatres some do screenings
and fundraisers throughout the year some
of many offshoot versions of themselves
like we have the horror one in October
we have but they want to stay relevant
and in and your success is their success
you know you're forever an alumni of
that festival so hey we're the
dead-center Film Festival this film we
played is doing well well that looks
reflects well on them and people that
they're sending that blast to saying
they're on VOD have been exposed to the
programs and you know festival genius
all those things that happen when we did
play there last summer so even if they
didn't see the film there's some brand
awareness that's important so moving
forward I think you definitely want to
have if you're going to do festivals a
big enough chunk and that's really what
you want to hit regardless on how much
money you spend this is my hands I don't
know why I'm doing
you